jellybeans daddy and I had a last-minute
business trip no I don't want you to go
jellybeans it was so hard to do that
scene without laughing I mean it's a
really serious scene it's a really
emotional intense crazy amazing scene
but it's ridiculous it's totally
ridiculous watching Paul Rudd take on
the mannerisms of Michelle we knew it
was a big swing to go for something like
as crazy as that and so everyone's on
board
story-wise but there's still the kind of
practicality of doing it so in those
moments when I'm tenderly putting my
hand on Michael Douglas's cheeks and
looking deep into his eyes it's almost
impossible not to giggle a ridiculous
abyss we really cracked up a lot Paul
yep that must say was brilliant kept it
straight the whole the whole way our
first fight in decades and it's over
just like that for me one of the tricky
things was looking at Paul and looking
into his eyes and feeling emotion but
not letting that emotion in any way she
performed be romantic there's like how
do I now shut that off and make it look
motherly and daughterly like that's a
whole other thing it was crazy
and we get up here
you